can i download some datasets from the
geo database and can I analyze my own
data using the tea violin for platform
so let's say I'm interested in this
functional analysis distinct disease
associated fibroblasts subsets in
rheumatoid arthritis and I'm interested
in finding that data associated with
this article so there's a recent article
on 2018 and I'm gonna look through here
I see all kinds of interesting figures
and I can read by the way what people
are doing here some single-cell RNA seek
so I know it's going to be
transcriptomic data it looks like this
is data from patients so most likely raw
data isn't going to be available but I
can see what they have so we have a
whole discussion here of methods and how
the library was prepared and then
single-cell RNA seek microarrays ok so
this was very interesting they did gene
set enrichment analysis differential
expression analysis so all of this you
can do on the t-bone platform you can
see here hierarchical clustering PCA so
all of the things that we already talked
about let's see where is the actual data
data availability so now you can see
that the data was deposited in geo and
this is the code so I can click on this
link and here's a thing that this system
is a little bit difficult to navigate
sometimes because now we need to look
for a very specific thing we're looking
for an FTP link a link that will allow
us to download the raw data now what you
will see here is that RNA seek analysis
of freshly isolated synovial fibroblast
subsets from patients with rheumatoid
arthritis so before we go into single
cell let's take a look at this data set
and you can see here that this is
transcriptomics
and this is taken from their arthritis
tissues and now you can see here that
data are not available due to patient
privacy concerns the raw data will not
be available through controlled access
resources the patients did not consent
to genomic data sharing okay so I know
I'm not going to have the raw fast Q
files but I can see right here I have 25
samples and these 25 samples are from
different donors and now this is
interesting
I have one two three four samples so for
patient sorry so I have this for
patients and now over here I have in TSV
format I have these FTP links looking
like this so I can already see some
things that I can recognize NSG this is
the gene and this is the expression
value so I know what we're dealing with
so basically what you will find is a
number of links so let's take a look at
that real quick so we have these genes
and we have these expression values and
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna open
the t bio info platform and if you
remember these sections right here this
is for processing raw data instead I am
interesting and analyzing this raw data
and I for example can try and replicate
some of the things that they did so just
as an example let's run a PCA pipeline
here the PCA pipeline is going to be
under the unsupervised analysis so one
thing that you will notice is that when
you upload files you get an svl HTTP or
FTP and you can just directly paste a
link here however the platform is going
to work with txt files and not and not
TSV file so I can simply rename this to
txt use txt
and now I'm just going to add files get
my txt file and what I want to do is if
you remember we have many samples here
is to run a PCA let's continue then
click on start and just to see what's in
there I'm gonna do PCA draw and leave it
as is and then end I'm going to do
rheumatoid arthritis PCA
and what we used here was count so this
is not normalized okay and let's run
this pipeline let's go to my pipelines
okay it's processing it's gonna wait a
second here okay and now I see that my
pipeline is done and what I can do is I
can go over here and I can see the PCA
plots as an example okay so let's take a
look at the PCA plots okay so now I can
see this plot that shows me a
distribution of samples and you can see
the names of the samples and associated
colors with those samples so what I want
to do next is I want to go and take the
same file instead of PCA try
hierarchical clustering so let's upload
the same file that we already used and
now instead of PCA we will do
hierarchical clustering okay here I will
change it to ward t2 and then let's do
it
download files okay so here's the PDF
let's take a look so here's our
dendogram and what I can see is at least
four clusters or maybe more that I can
already see right here now this would be
interesting to see what these samples
are let's go back and try to read a
little bit about these samples so we
have 25 samples from for rheumatoid
arthritis patients and over here we have
different patient names so we know that
four five and six and seven corresponds
to the patient name and then these are
some markers that they've identified but
I hope that this short tutorial has
demonstrated how you can take a
publication download the files
associated with that publication run
those files on the system and start to
question the data to understand what
might be behind the expression values